what's going on reject nation we're back
at it again
we're gonna do a try not to laugh for
family guy one that is perfect for both
john and i family guy roasting every
movie ever made
yes dust our hands off
all right okay i hope you're still
watching
you're asking the right questions now
you're being creative thinking outside
the box
take what you think you know and go a
different way with it like like for
instance
what if the daughter in taken was zoe
deschanel
send me your head okay okay
how many dirty stinking eggs does it
take to screw in a light bulb
three one dirty stinking egg to screw in
the light bulb
and two dirty stinking eggs to throw
feces at each other
we now return to the director's cut of
mission impossible five with the step
stools not edited out
with me because i'm definitely over six
feet and you're not handsome
cannibal has everything games food oh my
god it's the carol is from a christmas
story
that's right america don't forget your
beloved holiday movie
is incredibly weird and if i'm not that
wrong
oh my god roadhouse
i'll throw in what dreams may come with
robin williams no thank you
no charge i do not want it but it's free
sir if that dvd even touches roadhouse i
will kill you
don't worry someday someone will come
and take you home for their very own
well i guess it couldn't be worse than
that summer i spent in india
whatever you do short round don't touch
anything okay dr jones i don't touch
anything
hey be careful there's cars on the floor
here thanks that's weird huh
yeah the doorknob was really hot but i
just let go instead of holding onto it
and there's some ice on the stairs to
the basement so i guess
just don't go down there just you guys
know i have a tarantula
lost in the woods oh he makes a doll
that's not that strange it's kind of
what tom hanks did in castaway
i'm sorry we'll see
yes everyone can see that that's why we
call you scarface
[Music]
video from the ring peter don't they say
if you watch that video
you die yeah that's a lot of baloney
[Music]
he says worst case eight to twelve years
and when we get out
we'll still have the rest of our lives
ahead of us
goodbye terrible women taking us all by
surprise meg
like that realistic original ending to
dirty dancing
nobody puts baby in a corner i do
because i'm her father and she's 16.
what are you like 38 41
oh no
who you are i don't know what you want
but i have a very particular lack of
skills
i will never be able to find it but what
i do have
is two dollars and a casio wristwatch
you can have one of them
these guys are serious lois meg's dead
can now return to
[Music]
lois what's wrong clark we all have
breast cancer
the doctor says it's as if our breasts
have been x-rayed five hours a day
every day for the last three years oh my
god that's terrible first every woman
i've ever known and now you guys
i'm really excited you're humanely
relocating me to outside your house
oh yeah me and the fellas thought it was
time
is it on the machine i erased it
all right no ma yeller's my dog
i'll do it
[Music]
um
why he chose enchilada knife
peter we've had complaints from all over
town you're gonna have to stop with the
kiki
oh yeah i think my scary otherworldly
shadowy spirit friends might have
something to say about that
oh cool
all right
this is your last morning give me back
my wife what
excuse me give me back my wife or you're
in a lot of trouble
i'll kick all your faces you got me
you're kind of undoing everything you
just did when you kicked my ass
i know but i have to say for an audience
return to saving private ryan
brought to you without commercial
interruption by mazda
[Music]
what he lived happily ever after but he
did have to earn it
hit him do it charlie i'm not going back
to that four-person
and dorothy you wanted herbies but
little did you know you've had herpes
all along
i didn't want herpes oh
well you've got it
rocky might be in there thanks john
benjamin
talladega nights everywhere ladybugs
classic rodney
a million ways to die in the west no
thank you
please don't go to mars and fight the
martian i gotta do what i gotta do
but there's no oxygen on mars yeah that
means there's no oxygen for him either
that martian wants a fight he'll get a
yeah i had one when i was in high school
that'll be 27.50
you didn't see it ross and rachel got
back together it wasn't that great
[Music]
hello what is that on your ear is that
is that hair gel uh yeah oh great cause
i can use some
no no no don't i just ran out
okay now i'm an excellent nightmare so
you to get some much deserved sleep and
don't worry about a thing
i will take such loving care of this
wonderful little gift
and when you wake up well rested your
precious little baby
will be smiling as bright as the sun
don't
it's dead stewie shut up what it's just
a weird image
like the way commissioner golden tells
batman that he just took a poop
ugh i don't need to know about that
well i guess we're done yeah i guess
we're finished make a lot of breathing
noises john
that's that's how i try to refrain from
laughing as i just
channel it through my through my braces
i can't not
breathe while i'm stifling laughter all
right
so much breathing happened to my power
when i breathe i'm a joke star
now my favorite one was undoubtedly the
mazda joke absolutely
because i was like i don't even know
what they're like this is just out of
saving private ryan what's the mazda
joke here
like where are they gonna insert some
kind of inappropriate slogan and they
didn't disappoint me
literally it's the smallest ones the
ones that just surprised me the most
like with the ghostbusters one like guys
that take out uh
patrick swayze that's funny that'll be
27.50 this is so freaking funny
yeah so funny i feel like there's
probably like the roasting every movie
one they could do a gajillion of them i
think the smartest one is the home alone
one
that i mean that one you know got me in
the soul just because i've
always wondered what might have happened
in a world with more ruthless less
whimsical criminals
and i just feel like yeah they'd
probably get inside be like what is this
crap all over the floor oh damn
you know i didn't realize how much they
love clowning on patrick swayze yeah
he's in a lot of these
they really love clowning on patrick
swayze yeah man i mean he's been in so
many classics from ghost
to roadhouse and a bunch of things in
between i guess dirty dancing
but the smartest actually you know what
the smartest one to me might be
the the superman one with the x-rays and
how they develop cancer because of the
amount of
like peeping tom super pandas that's
pretty funny
every woman i've ever known and now this
is pretty good
and i mean it's always you know nice to
watch a filmmaker
take a a jab at themselves with that
million ways to die in the west uh crack
of course
the zoom zoom got me the best because it
was the best most effective
case of like really luring me in getting
me to focus like where are they gonna
come with me
you know and then surprisingly with
something nice so i think that was
still the the pinnacle try to laugh
family guy roasts in every movie i think
family guy's the best
to try not to laugh recommend some leave
them down below subscribe
click that notification bell maybe we'll
do trying to last a little bit more off
maybe like once a week anywho let's end
this with a pig
i want to shout out today zack feifel
because
zach feifel has sent over a try not to
laugh request for whose line is it
anyway i tried getting up on youtube i
ran a test
got blocked right away zack feifel i
know that you are going out there you're
trying to get us
to watch some videos that you're
recommending you constantly have
recommendations our way and i appreciate
that thoroughly i just want to say thank
you for your support i appreciate you
looking out looking for
ways to improve content and for finding
content for us that we could possibly be
very enjoyable for audiences to watch
and for us to enjoy as well
so thank you for being you dude and
appreciate your encouragement and
support
through and through buddy you be safe
you be well
much love to you keep finding the good
[Music]
stuff